The idea is that if we
have some other string that isn't the all-zero
vector and it isn't s, then each one of the random
strings, y1 through yk,
is basically going to knock
it out of the null space with probability a half.
So after k shots, it's not
at all likely to survive, and in fact, none of the
strings that don't belong
are likely to survive. And a very simple fact
from probability theory, known as the union bound, can
be used to establish that.
I haven't explained all
of the details here, but hopefully, you get the idea that by computing the null
space modulo-2 of this matrix m,
we are very likely to recover s, and that's how Simon's algorithm
solves Simon's problem.
There's just one thing left
to say about Simon's problem, and it concerns the classical
difficulty of this problem,
that is, how many queries does a classical query algorithm need to solve Simon's problem?
The answer is, a lot, in general.
There are different precise
statements that can be made about the classical
difficulty of this problem, and here's just one of them.
If we have any probabilistic
query algorithm and that algorithm makes fewer than 2 to the power n over 2
minus 1, minus 1 queries,
so that's a number of queries
that's exponential in n, then that algorithm will fail
to solve Simon's problem,
with probability at least a half.
Sometimes, proving
impossibility results like this can be very challenging, but this one isn't too difficult to prove
through an elementary
probabilistic analysis.
I won't do that in this video lesson, and I'll just instead focus
on the intuition behind it.
We're trying to find the hidden string s, but so long as we don't query the function on two strings having
the same output value,
we'll get very limited
information about s.
Basically, all we learn is
that the hidden string s is not the eXclusive OR of any two distinct
strings that we've queried,
And if we query the function at fewer than this number of queries, there will still be a lot of choices of s
that haven't been ruled out.
This isn't a formal proof,
but that is the basic idea.
So in summary, Simon's algorithm provides us with a striking advantage of quantum over classical
algorithms within the query model.
In particular, Simon's
algorithm solves Simon's problem with a number of queries that's linear in the number of input
bits n to our function,
whereas any classical algorithm,
even if it's probabilistic, needs to make a number of
queries that's exponential in n
in order to solve Simon's problem with a reasonable probability of success.
It's true that Simon's problem is a somewhat artificial problem that presumably nobody
really wants to solve,
but that's secondary. Sometimes ideas need to be developed before they're put into practice.
And indeed, Peter Shor has clearly stated that it was Simon's algorithm that inspired his now
famous quantum algorithm
for integer factorization, which we'll see in a couple of lessons.
And that is the end of Lesson 5.
In this lesson, we've taken a look at the
query model of computation, and we've seen a progression of examples
of quantum algorithms
that exhibit advantages over classical algorithms
within this model.
There is, in fact, a lot more
known about the query model and quantum algorithms for other problems that
I've not discussed.
So if you find this
model to be interesting, there's quite a lot
more to learn about it.
Our next step will be to move
away from the query model and toward a model of computation
that's more representative
of the sorts of problems that we might hope to solve in practice.
I hope you'll join me for Lesson 6, where will focus mainly on
laying down a foundation for studying quantum algorithms.
And from there, we'll move on to some
specific quantum algorithms, including Shor's algorithm
for integer factorization
in subsequent lessons. Goodbye until then!